[Music]
you
well good afternoon and to our our
fellow Americans out west good morning
we just completed today's meeting of the
White House coronavirus task force and
I'm pleased to be joined by many members
of the task force with us for this
briefing I want to thank Secretary azar
dr. Burks dr. Fauci dr. Redfield at the
CDC as well as our Attorney General dr.
Gerard of the US Public Health Service
dr. Hahn and Seema Verma will make a
series of presentations to update the
American people on the status of the
corona virus pandemic in the country and
then be available to take questions but
we very much appreciate the attendance
of all who are here and all of you who
have made time to tune in as we were
reported today we have now more than two
million 500,000 Americans that have
contracted the corona virus and sadly
we've lost more than 126 thousand of our
countrymen to this disease and I know I
speak for the President and for every
American when we express our sympathies
and our deepest condolences to all the
families who have lost loved ones
despite those losses since the end of
our 45 days to slow the spread and the
beginning of efforts to open up America
thanks to the cooperation of the
American people the efforts of governors
and state health officials efforts I
want to proudly say of the entire
federal team under the leadership of
President Trump we have made a truly
remarkable progress in moving our nation
forward we've all seen the encouraging
news as we open up America again more
than three million jobs created in the
last job report retail sale
are rolling and of course the
extraordinary progress in New York New
Jersey Connecticut and New Orleans areas
that just a matter of a month ago we're
struggling under the weight of this
pandemic and and now have arrived at a
very very different place as we stand
here today all 50 states and territories
across this country are are opening up
safely and responsibly but with cases
rising particularly over the past week
throughout the south
president Trump directed our task force
to brief the American people on several
topics first we we want to share with
you as dr. Burks will what we're seeing
in the rise of new cases that today
surmounted 40,000 new cases in a single
day secondly we want to speak about what
we've done and what we are doing at the
federal level to support state efforts
particularly in the states where we see
rising cases we'll talk today about
about how this moment in the corona
virus pandemic is different than what we
saw two months ago to better equip the
American people to respond and
ultimately we will speak about what
every American can do to play their part
in in reducing the spread and the
impacts of the corona virus pandemic for
our part also I've spoken to governors
in Arizona and in Florida and Texas in
the last 12 hours and dr. Burks and I
will be traveling on Sunday to Texas on
Tuesday to Arizona and I'll be traveling
to Florida on on Thursday of next week
to get a ground report and of course on
on Monday we will conduct what will be
our 26th weekly call with the entire
White House coronavirus task force and
all of the nation's governor's as we as
we meet this moment
as I mentioned it's important gathering
gathering today I think that we take
take a step back and think about how far
we've come as a country with the
president tapped me to lead the White
House coronavirus task force he said we
had one mission and that was to save
lives president Trump's decision to
suspend all travel from China in January
to stand up the White House coronavirus
task force in February to declare a
national emergency to halt travel from
Europe and amend travel from other
places around the country all
contributed to giving our nation time to
stand up a broad-based response the
whole-of-government response that we
spoke about so many times at the podium
throughout this pandemic we at the State
Department also coordinated the
repatriation of 95,000 Americans and
then came the moment when we brought
this chart to the President of the
United States on the Council of our very
best scientists the president was
presented with a decision that if we did
nothing no intervention the possibility
existed at that moment in time that we
could lose between 1.5 million and 2.2
million Americans but with intervention
and with mitigation by calling on the
American people to embrace the
mitigation effort social distancing that
were called upon first in the 15 days to
slow the spread that would become 45
days to slow the spread our best
scientists believe that we could we
could reduce the number of American
fatalities to a number ranging between
100,000 and 240,000 the president made
that decision and we unveiled the 15
days that became the 45 days to slow the
spread and in arguably as we see where
we are today
a nation because of what the American
people have done because of the
incredible work of our health care
workers because of a partnership with
governor's in every state we did just
that we slowed the spread we flattened
the curve we saved lives in the midst of
that we exponentially scaled testing
capacity partnering with private sector
commercial laboratories we we've now
reached some 30 million tests across the
country conducting some 500,000 tests a
day in that partnership with governor's
also the president directed us to make
sure that states had what they needed
when they needed it and at this point
I'm pleased to report that the that the
federal government both delivered and
facilitated the delivery of billions of
supplies of facials and gowns and gloves
and masks and we continue to be on track
to to construct more than a hundred
thousand ventilators in a hundred days
and as as I spoke to governor's last
night they confirmed to me again what
FEMA's reported we have no outstanding
requests from any state at this time for
personal protective equipment or medical
supplies let me say that again in the
affected areas particularly the states
down south that are seeing rising cases
we have no outstanding requests but as I
told the governor's we are ready at a
moment's notice to search personnel to
search supplies to expand capacity and
to support their health care response in
the midst of all of that I think it
always bears saying that because of the
great work of our health care workers
and because of American manufacturing no
American who required a ventilator has
ever been denied a ventilator in the
United States and I consider that
nothing short of a national
accomplishment we also surged hospital
capacity in areas of the greatest
anticipated need we send military and
National Guard a personnel
and these charts showing the progress
that we've made in new york and new
jersey and new orleans all demonstrate
the the efforts of the people of those
states in cooperation with federal
government all the great healthcare
workers to show the progress that we
made in areas that were once deeply
impacted and we extend our thanks we
extend our thanks to the people of each
of those states for the sacrifices that
they made during those great and
challenging times but at the close of
that 45 days to slow the spread we
unveiled a plan to safely reopen America
again and now all 50 states and
territories are moving forward and as I
said we're seeing America go back to
work and in much of the country where
we're seeing jobs expanding and economic
activity expanding but our focus today
is very much on on the advent of a
rising series of new cases across the
American South and where our first
mission was to save lives once we came
out of the 45 days to slow the spread
what our task force has been focused on
over the course of the past two months
is to partner with States to save lives
and safely reopen in fact we've we've
had some 17 meetings of the White House
coronavirus task force in the
intervening days since we began the
process of opening up America again and
we've been working very closely with
States to move that agenda forward
but as the president's made clear we we
want to open our economy up we want to
move America forward even while we take
and continue to take the steps necessary
to protect lives and the health of the
American people we stand here today
because with the with the rising cases
among southern states President Trump
asked us to brief the American people to
give details on what we're seeing what
we're doing
and how it's different from two months
ago as you may recall after seeing
overall cases drop from a thirty
thousand a day average in April to
twenty-five thousand a day of average in
May the first few weeks of June actually
saw cases averaging roughly twenty
thousand new cases a day we now have
seen cases begin to rise precipitously
across the south in fact 34 states 34
let me make sure I've got my numbers
exactly right here as we reported early
on 34 states across the country though
are experiencing a measure of stability
that is a credit to all of the people of
those states now when we speak about
stability we're talking about not
necessarily states where there are no
new cases but these would be states
where they're either no new cases and no
rising percentage or no combination of
those two things there may be states
across the country that are seeing a
modest increase in cases but their
percentage of positive rates is
remaining very stable and but
nevertheless there are 16 states with
rising cases and rising percentages and
we'll be focusing on those states today
the first thing we'd share with the
American people is that while there is a
a penchant in the national debate to use
a broad brush and to to paint an entire
state of one color if they're arising
cases in a portion of the state this is
actually a better picture of the data
that we literally analyze every single
day dr. Burks we'll take a few moments
to unpack the specific outbreaks in
Texas Florida Arizona and California but
the first thing we would convey to the
American people is that from this new
positive results in the last three days
you can see the the concentration of new
cases in specific parts of states
and of course very specifically in parts
of countries or parts of the country
secondly we want the American people to
understand it's almost in arguable that
more testing is generating more cases to
one extent or another the volume of new
cases coming in is a reflection of a
great success in expanding testing
across the country as I said at the top
we're testing more than ever before some
five hundred thousand people a day and
perhaps we could go to that testing
chart if it's there just to show you the
acceleration of testing that's taken
place over the course of this pandemic
in the United States it's truly been
remarkable and it's been a public and
private partnership from from the very
outset one of the things that we're
seeing among the cases we hear this in
Florida we hear this in Texas and
elsewhere
it's that roughly half of the new cases
are Americans under the age of 35 which
which is at a certain level very
encouraging news as the experts tell us
because as we know so far in this
pandemic that younger Americans are less
susceptible to serious outcomes of the
corona virus and the fact that we are
finding more younger Americans who've
contracted the corona virus is a good
thing and so we'll will speak about the
testing and Admiral Brett Gerar is here
and can detail any questions that you
might have about testing going forward
thirdly we'll we'll talk about what
these what these new numbers mean and
how we can address them a doctor fowey
will speak about that in just a moment
particularly in the affected areas and
the other area that we spend a great
deal time thinking about is is
hospitalization not only do we track new
cases every day
on a county-by-county basis but we also
track a hospitalization and the the map
on the left of your screen represents
how
you
some healthcare workers have the
resources and support they need again as
in the as in the matter of new cases you
can also see with hospitalization its
highly focused a highly detailed and
highly specific secretary a czar will
speak about hospitalization the work of
HHS to make sure that our hospitals
around the country have the capacity to
meet this moment but as dr. Burks may
well reflect as well we are encouraged
that we're two months ago we were seeing
some 15% of new cases being hospitalized
now that numbers averaging roughly 5%
around the country which is also
encouraging news to say the least and so
the while we while we have 16 states
that we're focusing on again I would
just reiterate to the American people
the most useful thing to know is where
it's happening so that you can take the
steps necessary to do your part but rest
assured in our conversations with
governor's in all of the most impacted
estates we continue to be assured that
hospital capacity remains strong and
they know the federal government stands
ready to provide them with the personal
protective equipment or supplies or even
expanded capacity and personnel to meet
any moment but at this point in time we
are told that that in all of the state's
most deeply impacted that
hospitalization remains very very
broadly available finally I want to
speak about the progress that we've made
as a country on the most difficult
aspect of this I said at the beginning
that our hearts and our prayers go out
to the families who've lost loved ones
in the course of the corona virus
pandemic man I I know I speak on behalf
of everyone in this country when I
extend our sympathies to the more than
hundred and twenty-six thousand families
that have lost loved ones as the
president has said many times one life
losses too many but nevertheless we I
believe at this point in the course of
the pandemic we can still take some
comfort in the fact that fatalities are
declining all across the country there
literally was a day two months ago this
week where we lost 2,500 Americans in a
single day this week because of the
extraordinary work of our health care
workers because of the availability of
new medicines like REM des aveer new
treatments like steroids and because of
the cooperation of the American people
heating the guidance that we gave at the
federal level and state and local
officials gave this week there were two
days where we lost less than 300
Americans and you can see from this
chart what has been a precipitous
decline from some of the worst moments
of this pandemic as it impacted areas of
New York and New Jersey and the
Northeast again I have a heavy heart any
time I recite these numbers but but the
fact that we are making progress
reducing the number of Americans that we
have lost and are losing I hope is an
encouragement because as we see new
cases rising and we're tracking them
very carefully there may be a tendency
among the American people to think that
we are we are back to that place that we
were two months ago that that we're in a
time of great losses and a great
hardship on the American people the
reality is we're in a much better place
with the with the efforts president
Trump mobilized at the federal level
with the efforts of this team this whole
of government approach the efforts of
governor's across the country are
incredible health care workers and the
cooperation of the American people we're
in a much stronger place the truth is we
did slow the spread we flattened the
curve we were able to stand up the
resources and the capacities in our
health care system to be able to meet
this
a virus in a way that would put the
health of all of our country first
we've also we also cared for the most
vulnerable and continue to focus
resources and testing and supplies on
the most vulnerable seniors with serious
underlying conditions and I believe with
all my heart that we've continued to
save lives we've created a solid
foundation for whatever challenges come
either in the days ahead or in the
months ahead and that's a credit that's
a credit I believe to our president to
our federal team to our state partners
mostly it's a credit to the American
people and our health care workers and
so we stand here today we believe we've
made progress but as we are reminded as
we see cases rising across the South
that we still have work to do and so we
say to every American particularly those
in counties and in states that are being
impacted by rising cases that now it's a
time for everybody to continue to do
their part and I think you'll hear from
this podium today a particular message
to younger Americans younger Americans
across the Sunbelt and the role that you
can play in protecting the vulnerable
making sure that while the coronavirus
doesn't represent as significant a
threat for a serious outcome to a
younger American none of us would want
to bring the disease back to our parents
or grandparents moms and dads an elderly
friend or a friend who has a an
immunodeficiency and cause a serious
outcome as well and so we leave you just
with the guidelines for all of the
phases when we put out the guidelines to
open up America again we laid out and at
the outset guidance for Responsible
reopening and states across the country
as I mentioned are doing just that 34
states are reopening safely and
responsibly and seeing
low and steady cases and not seeing a
rise in the percentage of positives and
in the 16 states that are being impacted
particularly those that we'll focus on
here today
we would just encourage every American
to follow the guidelines for all the
phases continue to practice good hygiene
wash your hands
avoid touching your face disinfect
frequently people who feel sick should
stay home and when it comes to
businesses social distancing protective
equipment temperature checks testing and
isolation these are the guidelines for
all of the phases and they are good
practices to to implement if you're in a
community that's affected or even if you
are not because we're all in this
together
and the progress that we made that you
saw illustrated in those charts and
places like New York and New Jersey
Connecticut and New Orleans was was a
result of the of the American people
stepping forward heeding the guidance of
federal state and local authorities and
we encourage you to continue to do just
that
you
but for those in the area's most
affected we just want to encourage you
to listen to and respect the guidance of
your state and local authorities
recognize that this is different than
two months ago both in our ability to
respond and in the nature of those that
are being infected and that younger
Americans have a particular
responsibility to make sure that they're
not carrying the coronavirus into
settings where they would expose the
most vulnerable and and lastly as I
prepare to bring dr. Burks at the podium
I just encourage every American to
continue to pray pray for all the
families that have lost loved ones pray
for our health care workers on the
frontlines and just continue to pray by
God's grace every single day will each
of us do our part to heal our land with
that I'll introduce the coordinator of
the White House effort on the
coronavirus dr. deborah birx thank you
mr. vice president thank you for that
great introduction just to remind
everybody where we have come from in the
last four months we have a great deal of
understanding now about the differential
disease differential infections no we
believe everybody is susceptible to
infection but we know infection leads to
a spectrum of disease and we have much
better details about who is vulnerable
and why they are vulnerable and as the
vice president said at one time we were
diagnosing people in the ICU after they
came into the emergency room and thanks
to the Millennials who have been heating
our guidance they have been coming
forward and getting testing and so
whereas before we told them to stay home
now we are telling them to be tested and
this is a great change for us because it
allows us now to find the asymptomatic
and the mild diseases that we couldn't
find before as dr. Redfield talked about
yesterday
from the serology tests we have a great
understanding of what was happening in
March and the number of
symptomatic and mild conditions that led
two individuals to have antibody but
never come forward with significant
disease we now know who's at risk for
significant disease and we now know it's
particularly the elderly individuals
over 80 and individuals with
comorbidities and remember those
comorbidities stand the entire age group
we do know that we have people in the
younger age groups with significant type
1 diabetes and may also have individuals
with significant obesity we know that
those are risk factors and so risk
factors go with your comorbidity not
necessarily with your age and so as we
call on individuals to protect one
another by passing someone on the street
you don't know what comorbidities they
have and this is why we've been focused
on trying to protect one another we also
know who's at risk for the highest
mortality and because of that we've been
able to the clinical care has
dramatically improved and I want to
thank NIH who has been working
constantly to update the clinical
guidelines so physicians around the
United States and frankly around the
world who are using those have the most
updated information about how to
actually improve disease courses of
those of interview that are in the
hospital
we of course have improved treatment in
the hospital that we didn't have in
March and April with improved methods of
oxygenation which is really quite
important improve treatment of acute
respiratory distress that's that
individuals on the ventilator we know
now will respond quite well to steroids
and then research that is ongoing on
what we call the acute cytokine storm
that is when often in that later stage
when people are on ventilators they see
this seriously ill may need steroids and
other items and that's being researched
and the work that's being done on
clotting research by the NIH we also
have new therapeutics that have been
used both as compassionate use like
convalescent plasma and now render
severe that we just reallocated and
ensured it was available to these states
that are facing the increased
hospitalization as well as that monthly
allocations that we have been sending
out
we can go to the first slide please and
start where the vice president laughs
left off a really this disease is
tackled community by community testing
at the community level and working with
community groups to understand the
spread in those communities and so we've
spent the time to really map this
epidemic and new positives down to the
level of communities to understand where
spread is occurring so that we can match
our prevention interventions to those
areas next slide please
as we discussed and it's difficult for
you to see on this graphic because the
top line is New York and we should
remember where we were and that slope
that early slope that you can see in the
case of the New York cases that rapid
acceleration on the same slide you can
see California that is the blue line
that is just passing the orange line and
also on the slide is Texas and Green
Florida and orange and Arizona at the
bottom as dramatic as these slopes are
they are not equivalent to the original
acceleration that we saw in New York
that doesn't mean that we aren't
absolutely focused on working with the
governors and those communities to stop
the spread of the virus in those four
states next slide please
this shows you through the entire
country that we're tracking state by
state now obviously this axis is vastly
different than the one on the prior
slide because that slide included all of
the cases in New York City but you can
see on this slide that we've been
tracking very closely North Carolina a
team's been in with North Carolina
working with the state and local public
health authorities to really respond to
the changes there as well as the South
Carolina at the bottom next slide I'll
just go quickly through these so you can
see Oklahoma's at the bottom of this
slide and next slide you can see on this
slide Idaho and Oregon those are the
ones in the light blue and the dark
green where you see an inflection in
their slopes these inflection points and
understanding when they occur and why
they occur
are critical for understanding how to
prevent the spread next slide now what
the vice president talked about is we've
created an alert system that brings
together what we just talked about
rising cases with an understanding of
test positivity and so this really this
chart which is difficult for you to see
those states on that far side to have
the highest test positive that you can
see at the higher level of the graph
those are the states that we have
concerns about because the rising number
of cases and the rising test positive
this in this explains the extent of
community spread in states that have
increasing cases but falling test
positives it tells us that they're
getting into the communities to find the
asymptomatic cases and so these are the
things we put together to understand the
full picture next slide please
so this really puts on one slide the
states that we have that we've been
talking about across the South where we
have our greatest concerns the two top
states with the largest increase in test
positives are Texas and Arizona followed
by Florida Mississippi South Carolina
Alabama Georgia Louisiana Nevada and
Utah those last views in three states
are under still 10% but we're tracking
them closely as we look at that
individually finally next slide you can
see on this slide we are tracking and
this is when you hear about we have a
certain two percent or three percent of
the counties under specific alerts so it
doesn't matter the size of the county
we're tracking the increase in the rate
of increase at new cases at the county
level we currently have about a hundred
and thirty counties out of the 3,000 and
100 in the United States in that
category next slide
to level this shows you the case
positivity by the metros and the number
of tests that have been done next slide
and then this shows you specifically the
change over time of test positivity in
the largest metros where we have
concerns and this is Austin
Phoenix Houston Dallas San Antonio Tampa
Orlando Miami Riverside California and
Atlanta at the bottom and so this is how
we continue to integrate data on cases
data on testing and data on
hospitalizations so that we can work
with the states for a comprehensive
integrated response next slide I know
you many of you would be interested in
seeing how high the test positivity rate
became in April and May well March in
April so that top line is New York City
Metro and you can see it reached over
50% on a series of days for almost two
weeks 50% of the tests were positive for
kovat 19:00 underneath that you see New
Jersey and Minnesota and a whole series
of individuals Detroit is a second the
second large Mountain next slide so
quickly to show you how we look at this
at the state level and work with the
governors and the local health
authorities so this is Florida we track
testing it's done the number of test
positives that are in the blue line the
total number of cases seen in the black
bar and what we call this syndromic
presentations of early respiratory
diseases and pneumonias next slide this
then we look at the county level to look
for changes in the slope of a number of
new cases so you can see that top county
that has the largest increase in slope
in cases is Miami miami-dade followed by
Broward and Palm Beach all the other
counties are much lower in their daily
case increases this allows us to focus
resources and testing along with the
state into these specific sites next
slide that all comes together to keep
the to create this graphic so that
individuals can understand and we
understand precisely whet the rate of
growth is and where the rate of growth
is occurring by the shading of the boxes
now I'm going to quickly take you
through Texas because it's the same
story next slide so this shows you the
exact same graphics now shown for Texas
showing a continued rise in the daily
tests performed but also a rise in the
test positivity the blue line you can
see throughout May after opening their
test positivity continued to decline as
their testing increased it was in the
last two and a half weeks that we saw
this inflection of rising test
positivity along with rising testing but
it was the increase in test positivity
that alerted us along with the increased
cases that this was becoming an alert
you can see in the red boxes everything
is heat mapped so at a glance you can
tell those two boxes that are in the
middle that are red that's the heat map
che c'è showing that this has rising
cases and rising test positivity next
slide but even in Texas next slide
please
and this gives you a map of Texas or
shows where the cases are and where
they're rising the most rapidly and
finally I'm just gonna go through
Arizona
very quickly along with California so
next slide same situation that we're
showing here with Arizona rising number
of tests being performed but also rising
test positivity rise in cases next slide
Arizona is unique and they have
essentially one County that is primarily
represented by the depth of the new
cases and this is in the Phoenix area
next slide
then next slide so this is California
and so you can see California over the
last week has had that increase in test
positivity you can see that dramatic
increase at the end of that bar in the
blue line along with still increasing
test positive testing that has been done
and we just want to thank all of the
governors and all of the work at all the
laboratories that has allowed
along with HHS and Brett tirar who
ensured that the supplies were there to
really increase these orange lines you
could see in each of these cases these
orange lines have dramatically gone up
over the last four weeks next slide and
like New Mexico the primary infections
right now in California at the highest
level are in the LA area but because la
is a large metropolitan area next slide
you really need this kind of more
specific and local graphic to really
show that it's also increasing in the
Central Valley and this gives us the
ability to focus resources among
agricultural workers to improve testing
and isolation for those who to become
positive so I just wanted to take you
through how we've been looking at data
how we consolidate that data and then
Monday report it out to the governor's
we hope over the next week to be able to
really have this data available in real
time on the White House website so that
everybody across the country can see
where the cases are because in the end
we really want to call to the action
when we started talking about what can
be done we said the most important thing
that would change the spread and I'm
gonna turn that over because I know
Tony's going to talk about it is really
individual behavior and our respect for
one another through social distancing
wearing a mask and ensuring that we're
protecting the most vulnerable that
maybe in multi-generational households
and I just want to end by thanking again
the Millennials who have come forward
and I know during the protests we asked
a lot of them to go forward to get
testing and we see those testing rates
really improving in the under 40 age
group that is going to be important to
continue to accelerate testing among the
under 40 age group because that's the
age group most likely to have a
symptomatic spread and be spreading the
virus unbeknownst to them and I want to
really make it clear no one is
intentionally spreading the virus but
they don't know that they're positive
they don't have symptoms and need to be
tested in order to have that awareness
and so we really want to thank them
again for coming forward and really
enriching the amount of tests
that has been done in the under 40 under
40 year old age group and to our older
population you know if you have
comorbidities you know if you're over 80
we asked you if in the hot spots in
these states that are having expansion
in cases to continue to shelter as much
as you can and use your grandchildren to
go and do your shopping thank you very
much dr. Bergson and Thank You mr. vice
president so I want to extend just for a
couple of minutes some of the comments
that were made both by the vice
president and by dr. Burks and it has to
do with the situation that we're we find
ourselves facing right now it's very
clear from the maps that you saw that
there are certain areas in the country
states towns cities regions that are
doing very well that will follow the
guidelines and are opening up in a
prudent way that's been effective
however as you can see we are facing a
serious problem in certain areas now
when you look at the map it's very
interesting because you see some dark
parts of the map and some light parts of
the map we have a very heterogeneous
country but heterogeneity does not mean
that we are not intimately
interconnected with each other so it
goes on in one area of the country
ultimately could have an effect on the
other areas of the country so let's take
a look at this problem that we're facing
now this resurgence of cases I don't
think there's time enough now all day to
try and analyze and figure out the
multi-faceted elements that went into
that you know everything from maybe
opening a little bit too early on some
to opening at the right time but not
actually following the steps in an
orderly fashion to actually trying to
follow the steps in an orderly fashion
but the citizenry did not feel that they
wanted to do that for a number of
reasons likely because everyone feels
the common feeling of being pent up for
such a long period of time so we're not
going to say blame we're not going to
try and analyze it but there is
something that's very important about it
that I'd like to get a message to the
country in general
when you have an outbreak of an
infectious disease it's a dynamic
process that is global so remember what
happened in China affected us what
happened in Europe affected us what's
happening here is affecting others we
can't get away from that
it's interconnected so therefore if we
are an interconnected society we've got
to look at the fact of what our role is
in trying to put an end to this force
everybody wants to end it everybody
wants to get back to normal and
everybody wants the economy to recover I
think we all are pretty common in that
that's a given
so what can we do what I think upon
talking to a lot of people and
reflecting on it we are such an unusual
situation because of all of the decades
that I've been involved in chasing
infectious diseases I've never seen
anything that is so protein in its
ability to make Sikh people sick or not
there's no other infectious disease that
goes from 40% of the people having no
symptoms to some having mild symptoms to
some having severe some requiring
staying at home for weeks some going to
the hospital some getting intensive care
some getting intubated some getting
ventilated and some dying so that
depending on where you are in that
spectrum you have a different attitude
to this particular thing but anyone who
gets infected or is it risk of and
getting affected to a greater or less
degree is part of the dynamic process of
the outbreak and I know because I can
understand when I was at a stage in my
life when I said well I'm invulnerable
so I'm gonna take a risk I think what
we're missing in this is something that
we've never faced before is that a risk
for you is not just isolated to you
because if you get infected you are part
innocently or inadvertently
of propagating the dynamic process of a
pandemic because the chances are that if
you get infected that you're going to
infect someone else and although you may
feel well
because we know if you look at the
numbers that you're probably care later
on the overwhelming majority now if
people are getting infected our young
people likely the people that you see in
the clips and in the paper or out in
crowds enjoying themselves
understandably no blame they're
understandably but the thing that you
really need to realize that when you do
that you are part of a process so if you
get infected you will infect someone
else who clearly will infect someone
else we know that happens because the
reproduction element of the virus is not
less than one so people are infecting
other people and then ultimately you
will infect someone who's vulnerable now
that may be somebody's grandmother
grandfather uncle who's on chemotherapy
and who's on radiation or chemotherapy
or a child who has leukemia so there is
what I call and again I just want to
bring this out without making it seem
that anybody's at fault you have an
individual responsibility to yourself
but you have a societal responsibility
because if we want to end this outbreak
really end it and then hopefully when a
vaccine comes and puts the nail in the
coffin we've got to realize that we are
part of the process so when the Vice
President went back pulling back a
couple of months ago when we showed
about the guidelines to safely reopen
the country we've got to make sure we
drop back a few yards and think about
that that this is part of a process that
we can be either part of the solution or
part of the problem so I just want to
make a plea with people when they
understand the stress that they're under
as we try to tackle not only those
states but the light-coloured part of
the country even though they've done
well they may have gotten hit badly like
New York and then came down or they may
not have gotten hit badly at all they
are vulnerable if we don't extinguish
the outbreak sooner or later
even ones that are doing well
all gonna be vulnerable to the spread so
we need to take that into account
because we are all in it together and
the only way we're going to end it is by
ending it together thank you well first
thank you all for joining us here at HHS
to update the American people I want to
begin by thanking everyone around the
country working to defeat this virus all
of the healthcare providers on the front
lines those working to reopen our
economy safely the American people who
have sacrificed so much in this fight
and the incredible numbers of our HHS
team who've been working tirelessly to
protect the health and well-being of all
Americans before covering today's topic
I want to mention a major milestone for
global health yesterday the end of the
second largest Ebola outbreak in history
in the eastern Democratic Republic of
the Congo we congratulate the Congolese
government and all of the health care
workers and community members involved
some of whom I had the chance to meet
and thank in the DRC last fall under
President Trump the United States was
proud to play a bigger role in this
major public health victory than any
other single nation and now thanks to
the president and the vice president's
leadership and the hard work of our team
America has never been ready or to
combat Cova 219 we've built up our
readiness under the strategy we
developed to address surges save lives
and in time defeat the virus we're in a
much stronger position to support States
hospitals and individuals as they fight
back there are six parts to the strategy
surveillance testing containment health
care capacity therapeutics and vaccines
first we've been strengthening
surveillance so that we can be aware of
and respond to surges that means for
instance being able to track more cases
among younger Americans that we never
would have caught earlier in the
pandemic second we have the world's
greatest testing capabilities enabling
us to confirm the presence of the virus
when it crops up and we're confident
that capacity will continue to rise in
the coming months
third states are building the capacity
to track and contain outbreaks of the
virus with
federal help many states have
substantially expanded their own
capabilities and were deploying
knowledgeable experienced CDC and HHS
public health teams to the area's now
seeing increases with a focus on
community testing and community based
interventions forth were helping health
care systems secure sufficient capacity
and supplies we've dramatically expanded
American manufacturing of PPE and the
FDA has authorized new technologies to
sterilize equipment for reuse we spoken
with hospitals and states that are
building up their own PPE reserves many
of them getting up to 60 or 90 days of
supplies through the strategic national
stockpile we have far more visibility
into the supply needs across the country
including centralized coordination
capabilities that we lacked just a few
short months ago visiting healthcare
providers around the country I've seen
how they're adapting to bring patients
back while taking appropriate
precautions America's hospitals are
ready to get back to business while
maintaining their readiness for kovat 19
the fifth and sixth elements of the
strategy are thanks to the president's
operation warp speed
we now have promising therapeutics that
are benefiting tens of thousands of
American patients and in all likelihood
have already saved thousands of lives
we've identified two very promising
pharmaceutical treatments REM Desa beer
and dexamethasone as of today we've
allocated more than 120 thousand courses
of REM no severe to all of the 50 states
we've added dexamethasone a very low
cost steroid to our treatment guidelines
and we believe it's reasonable to assume
that other corticosteroids which may be
more readily accessible in some places
would have similar amine illogical
effects another promising therapeutic
convalescent plasma has been used to
treat more than 25,000 Americans in
nearly 3,000 sites across the country
there are no certainties in science but
with more than 140 clinical trials
underway in the US it's a pretty safe
bet that more good news on therapeutics
is on the way and on the way soon
finally we've announced large
investments to support three different
manufacturing can de de taüll the way
through to manufacturing
during these candidates are now in human
clinical trials some with the potential
to start delivering safe and effective
doses before the end of the year and
we'll be adding support for several more
candidates we're expanding manufacturing
capacity and already making the vials
needles and syringes that we may need
our capabilities have grown
exponentially in the time allowed by the
patriotic sacrifices of the American
people we have a much better grasp of
the virus as dr. Burke said and much
more data with which to model it with
that data as you've heard today we can
focus on local trends we have some very
concerning hotspots and we can track
when other hotspots emerge as we expect
they may we're focused on the states and
the counties within those states just
three percent of counties that represent
hotspots it's important for the American
people to be aware of this variability
in variation across the country
Americans need to understand their local
trends because we want to help people
make the right decisions for themselves
making decisions for yourself has to be
based on three axes of risk as our
Surgeon General taught us in March you
want to assess where you are who you are
and whom you live with and what activity
you're thinking about doing there there
are gradations of risk within each of
these axes going to an outdoor
restaurant in Montana is a great deal
different from a crowded indoor bar in
Houston when you interact with fewer
people in an activity when you interact
with them for a shorter period of time
your risk is reduced and individuals can
balance these kinds of factors what I've
laid out today is remarkable progress by
the president's administration and a
particular credit to the team here at
HHS we've got a lot of work ahead of us
but Americans can be confident that we
have a rock-solid foundation to help us
get safely back to work back to school
back to worship and back to health care
while we tackle surges of the virus
where they occur thanks to president
Trump's leadership we've got the
capabilities the knowledge and the
strategy to protect Americans lives of
their livelihoods at the same time and
every American should feel proud of that
thank you
Thank You mr. vice president I wanted to
add some comments once again I want to
stress and thank all Americans to
embrace the importance of social
distancing recommendations to slow the
spread of covin as I've said before
we're not defenseless these are in fact
very powerful weapons and it's our
collective responsibility to recommit
ourselves to put them into routine
practice again to stay six feet apart
from each other as much as possible to
wear face coverings when we're in public
and to practice vigorous hand hygiene
and to commit to do so as we've heard
today to do our part to protect the
vulnerable I also want to appeal to the
Millennials and those that are under 40
it's really important that this group
really commit themselves to these
practices to protect those at risk and
it's not just the elderly that at risk
many of us may have friends and
colleagues that are younger that may not
advertise their underlying comorbidities
as the case would be with say type 1
diabetes or an underlying immune
deficiency so again asking this team
Millennials and younger people in this
country to come and commit themselves I
agree with ambassador birx were very
thankful that the group is now coming
forward to get tested but I also want
this group to put into vigilant practice
the importance of our social distancing
the ones thing that I wanted to stress
though is that there are differences in
what we're experiencing today then what
we all experienced in March in April and
May and one of the things I want us to
focus on is not the cases per se but the
consequences the impact of those cases
it wasn't long ago probably within two
months ago it's hard to believe I don't
think many people realize that 27
of all deaths that occurred in the
United States actually died of a
pneumonia
that was a pneumonia could have been
influenza could have been Kovan 27
percent one in four of all the deaths in
the United States just two months ago
was caused by pneumonia I'm happy to say
today the destin'd ammonia in this
nation's back to baseline it's about
seven percent it's a big difference a
lot of those pneumonias that were dying
were actually covin in fact individuals
that were the elderly nursing homes and
individuals with comorbidities we are
seen despite these increased cases we
have seen a progressive decline in
deaths the lasts a two week a verge
deaths in the United States now is
around six 650 and as you heard the vice
president it wasn't long ago that sadly
we were losing 25,000 individuals a day
so I think it's critical that we
continue to focus on on on that the
consequences and it's part of that why
it's important that we continue also to
look forward to how we deal with in
contain and control the COBIT infection
but as we also change the consequences
of the impact it's had on education in
this country or as an economy in
business so again as I close I want to
just rewritten for now for individuals
to really think seriously as Tony said
about the responsibility to others that
we have because this infection pathogen
really does have the capacity to cause
quite serious illness in individuals at
high risk and in brief embrace our
nation's recommendations that the vice
president put up again that we have for
all phases of reopen in America again I
also want to thank the younger groups
for stepping forward and getting tested
clearly what we're seeing now is this
age group is much more likely to be
asymptomatic and and again
to make that commitment to do
their part to protect those of us that
whether we're young or old have a
comorbidity and would be more vulnerable
to serious illness from this virus thank
you very much
questions yes please well the the
freedom of speech the right to peaceably
assemble is enshrined in the
Constitution of the United States and we
have an election coming up this fall and
president Trump and I believe that
taking proper steps as we created
screening at recent events and and
giving people the very best counsel that
we have we still want to get people to
freedom to participate in the political
process and we respect that I was I was
pleased to see that now the better part
of a week since we were in Oklahoma I
think their positivity rate is actually
declined as of today and that's a great
testament to the fact that people are
using common sense they're being
responsible they know and understand
what's happening in the community in
which they live and our emphasis today
is really to say that we think it's it's
most helpful if if the American people
understand that what we're seeing across
the South today is really outbreaks and
their outbreaks that are in specific
counties in some cases their outbreaks
that are in specific communities and
we've surged CDC personnel HHS personnel
I didn't mention before but three weeks
ago when we were seeing similar activity
North Carolina and Alabama we sent
personnel into those states and we've
actually seen declining numbers
beginning in both of those states so the
important thing is it not not one size
fits all the overall guidance to every
American to practice good hygiene to
practice the measures that we
recommended at home and at work stand
but but our focus today is to make sure
that in those areas of the country where
we're seeing a significant not only
increase in cases but an increase in
positivity level that the American
people know just how important it is to
listen to what their state and local
health officials are directing them to
do please the decision not to wear a
mask are you concerned about that and is
there a message that you would like to
send to people about the importance of
wearing masks well we we think that
we're the first principle is that people
ought to listen to their state and local
authorities I mean III have to tell you
President Trump and I couldn't be more
grateful for the partnership we forged
with governor's around the country I
spoke to the governor of Florida of
Arizona of Texas just within the last 12
hours and I told them that from this
podium today we would remind their
citizens to to heed the guidance in the
direction of state and local officials
in some cases there's statewide guidance
with regard to facial coverings and with
regard to events and gatherings in other
cases there are specific county wide or
city wide directives and we just believe
that what's most important here is that
people listen to the leadership in their
state and the leadership in their local
community and adhere to that guidance
whether that have to do with facial
coverings whether it have to do with the
size of gatherings and we'll continue to
reinforce that message please
what is the correlation between the
spike in cases that we're seeing in
states like Texas and Florida and the
way those states handled to read their
reopening was it too much too soon and
secondly I wanted to ask dr. pouchy you
said in an interview that quote
something is not working what isn't
working and did you all in your meeting
today come up with a plan to fix
whatever isn't working well let me
respond first and then I'll let dr.
Fauci address it as well and dr. Burks
me as well I think there will be a
temptation for people to look at of
these Sunbelt states that have been
reopening and putting people back to
work and and suggest that the reopening
has to do with what we're seeing in the
last week or so but frankly in the case
of each of these states they reopened in
some cases almost two months ago and and
their test cases their new cases that
from testing was low and steady their
positivity rate was low what we're
observing today and I've heard this from
Florida I've heard this from Texas and
some other states along the Sun Belt is
that we're seeing more and more young
people under the age of 35
who are testing positive in many cases
they have no symptoms but they're coming
forward and confirming that they that
they have contracted the corona virus
we're working with the states as you
speak about our plan we've got we've got
CDC personnel embedded in every state in
the Union
we're surging more CDC personnel as
requested to each of these states to
help them unpack what the data is
suggesting I know the governor of Texas
announced some new measures this morning
which we fully support but what we're
going to continue to do is give give our
state leadership the very best
information that
best counsel that we have and and and if
there's one message that comes through
today I hope it is it is saying to
younger Americans in these states and in
these counties in particular that they
are a big part of the numbers that we
are seeing in new cases and while there
may not be a significant threat of a
serious health outcome to them
I know of no young person and I got I
got three 20-somethings in my immediate
family no young person would ever want
to inadvertently expose a mom a dad a
grandmother grandfather or someone who's
vulnerable to a serious result and so
alerting them that there's been spread
among that age group urging them to take
countermeasures and heed with their
governors and and local officials are
directing will be our continued strategy
dr. Fauci did you want to be smart so
what I meant by what is not working and
this is not anybody's fault or any
institutions fault is that what we're
dealing with right now is community
spread in the context of a substantial
proportion of the people who are getting
infected do not know they're infected
they're not symptomatic they're
asymptomatic individuals the classic
paradigm of identification isolation and
contact tracing to actually contain that
is very difficult to make that work
under those circumstances you
superimpose upon that the fact that even
with identification isolation and
contact tracing often the dots are not
connected if you get on the phone and
talk to people who are in some of these
communities you find that a lot of it is
done by phone and when it's done by
phone maybe half of the people don't
even want to talk to one who they think
as a government representative if you
live in a community that is mostly brown
or black you're in a different situation
that maybe 70% of them don't really want
to talk to you you can identify it
contact but you don't isolate them
because you don't have the facility to
isolate them that is what's not working
so what we're going to do and we
doing and you're gonna be hearing about
this you know flooding the sich flooding
the area of a community to get a feel
for what's out there particularly among
the asymptomatic s' so in other words
it's a paradigm shift because we're
dealing with young people people who are
going to be asymptomatic and people who
are getting infected in a community
setting not an outbreak setting will you
know who to identify isolate and contact
trace that's what I meant
good night and I just want to finish it
expand thought for just a second um
about three months ago we talked about
how important it was to have community
at the center and I think when you talk
about what's going to be different and
part of the reason why the president
vice president have asked me to go out
to Texas New Mexico and Arizona is to
not only meet with the state and local
health officials but to meet with the
community groups so that the community
groups can help us support community
specific messaging public health
messaging when you just keep saying the
same thing over and over again and the
people get tone-deaf to it it's because
it's not tailored to their specific
circumstances and they don't see that
message resonating in their lives we've
had to do this across the world I've
done this over and over again for HIV TB
and malaria at the center of this has to
be the community and the community will
help us identify who needs to be tested
to help us identify which households
have the most vulnerability in them and
how we can really go into those
communities and support that response at
a very local and ground level when we
started this we're a very much facility
based and we know facilities carry us a
long way but if we want to change the
transmission rates in these metros in
specific communities and in civic parts
of those metros we've got to walk
side-by-side with our community leaders
and our community groups that know how
to translate our scientific dogma and
information down to a lover level where
people will understand it hear it and
act on it I know when they hear it and
understand
and it they will act on it and so that's
hot when you ask what's gonna be
different that has already started and
it's already going to be different just
let me add to that that's exactly what
we did with HIV 30 years ago we got the
community involved in helping us to
outreach and I think that's very
important to underscore what dr. Burke
said and that's exactly what's being
planned to do to get people who know the
community who live in the community who
the community trusts rate to go up in
the next three or four weeks just like
we're seeing the rate of infection go up
now well our hope and our prayers is not
the case we've seen as you as you noted
we've seen a precipitous decline in
fatalities and again I one is too many
we grieve the loss of every American
life but the fact that two months ago we
had lost 2,500 Americans in a single day
in two days this week we lost less than
300 Americans it is a testament to our
health care workers to all of the
medicines that secretary a czar just
described being being available in all
50 states it's a testament to the
efforts of the American people and we
hope as we continue to engage that we'll
continue to see those numbers decline
the other reason we're encouraged is
because at this point when we look at
our losses roughly two point five
percent of all of our losses took place
in people under the age of 25 I mean
younger Americans and in each case or at
least 90 percent of the cases they were
people with with pre-existing conditions
underlying conditions that contributed
to the sad outcome so as we see that in
Florida and in Texas they've reported to
us that half or even more than half of
the new cases that are show
up every day our people under the age of
35 are younger Americans in most cases
asymptomatic our hope is is that that
those younger healthy Americans like
most have already will continue to go
through the coronavirus will recover but
our message today as we've spent so much
energy in the last four months
protecting the most vulnerable maybe
we've deployed testing resources we've
supported States efforts states across
the country in the last month have
answered our call to test all the
residents of their nursing homes to set
up a plan to test all of the staff on a
regular basis we need to protect the
most vulnerable and we want a message
going out to younger Americans
particularly those along the Sunbelt in
these counties where we see new cases on
the rise positivity on the rise to know
that we we need them to do their part to
make sure and protect and the most
vulnerable so that we can so that we
don't see those losses arise but it's
it's in the hands of the American people
and particularly young people in this
country
right there you're saying do as we say
not as we do you're telling people to
listen to local officials but in Tulsa
you defied local health officials to
have an event that even though you say
it didn't result in a spike dozens of
Secret Service agents dozens of campaign
staffers are now quarantined after
positive tests and then in Arizona when
the hardest hit States you packed a
church with young people who weren't
wearing masks so how can you say that
the campaign is not part of the problem
that doctor thought you laid out well I
want to remind you again that the
freedom of speech and the right to
peaceably assemble is enshrined in the
Constitution of the United States and
even in a health crisis the American
people don't forfeit our constitutional
rights and working with state officials
as we did in Oklahoma and as as we did
in Arizona we're creating settings where
people can choose to participate in the
political process and and we'll continue
to do that it I think it's I think it's
really important that we recognize how
important how important freedom and
personal responsibility are to this
entire equation and but allowing
allowing younger Americans allowing
Americans to understand particularly in
the counties that are most impacted the
unique challenges that we're facing in
their age group we think is important
but look it's it's it's so important
that we recognize that as we issued
guidance to reopen America now two
months ago and now as all 50 states are
opening up our country again people are
going back to work American everyday
life is being restored kind of one step
one day at a time I think it's important
that we remind ourselves this is not a
choice between the health of the
American people
and a strong economy there are profound
health implications to the lockdowns
through which we just passed I heard it
I heard a statistic not long ago at a at
a at a task force briefing that in one
jurisdiction there'd been a 50% increase
in the number of people presenting at
emergency rooms having attempted suicide
I mean their profound mental health
issues there are profound economic
issues people needing to be back to work
and and so we're we're our objective
here today is just to make sure the
American people know in 34 states the
cases are largely stable and there's no
combination of rising cases and rising
positivity rates that's a tribute to the
American people and in the in the 16
states were focused on today we simply
want to we want to equip particularly
young people with the knowledge of the
part that they can play in stemming the
rising tide of new cases not because the
corona virus represents a significant
threat to them in most cases it doesn't
if you're a younger American but because
we don't know younger American would
ever want to spread the corona virus to
someone who would have a serious outcome
but I'm I'm grateful for the time today
we hope this has been helpful
and we'll be back more information this
time goes on thank you
[Music]
[Music]